all right all right so i guess this kind
of connects but the question is can you
explain imputed right righteousness
imputed righteousness is what god does
for us
in part of the righteousness imperialize
is what he does in us
uh when you come to christ
a sinner i'm sorry forgive me
immediately christ's righteousness
covers you
and his righteousness stands in your
place
now listen to what you said stands in
your place
let me put it this way
you're in school university of
missouri city
and you get
f
e
g plus h minus those are your grades are
you with me
now you come to christ
and you submit to him
read out christ's score for me a plus a
plus a plus a plus a plus plus plus
those are the grace christ has in
righteousness he puts that to your name
when you come to him
let me tell you why that's necessary
a perfect life the bible says the law of
the lord is perfect
a perfect law requires a perfect life
you said amen but did you get what i'm
saying
a perfect law cannot tolerate an
imperfect life
if it tolerated it it ceases to be a
perfect law a perfect lord demands a
perfect life
which means you have to be perfect in
the past
in the present
and you must be perfect in the future
are you with me the only person who's
lived that life is christ
so when you come to christ
and you truly surrender you convicted by
his love as expressed on calvary you
want to do everything that pleases him
but the spirit is willing but the flesh
is me you understand
christ accepts you and covers you with
his righteousness and so eloise writes
in step to christ page 62 paragraph two
if you give yourself to him
and accept him as your savior then
sinful as your life may have been
for his sake you're counted righteous
christ's character is put in place of
your character and you are accepted by
god just as if you had never sinned
okay okay give me one minute
this is so astounding people don't
believe it
they don't believe it the gospel is the
most astonishing that's why angels
cannot understand it
that the very listen to second
corinthians 5 21 for he god the father
hath made him christ to be sin for us
whom you know sin as christ and you know
sin that we might be made the
righteousness of god in him
we must be made righteous
because we cannot make ourselves
righteous
god was god made jesus to be sin because
jesus never made himself sin by sinning
and so imputed righteousness is what is
given to us
when we come to christ the important
righteousness is that power that takes
us from day to day
one is our title to heaven that's
imputed the other is our fitness for
heaven for instance let's say my little
brother is 12 and he's next in line to
be king of some country in europe
somewhere but he's only 12.
now he has to wait till he's 18. he has
the title but he does not have the
fitness are you with me let me say it
again he has the title but he doesn't
have the sickness so when you come to
christ i'm sorry like that publican in
luke 18
he left
with the right
the title he now had to develop the
fitness or christ had to work out the
fitness in him and so imputed is a title
imparted provides the fitness
for
a place in god's kingdom yes my brother